[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour café politique
bonne année à tous et bonne année à
Joséphine colmans berger bonjour bonne
année et bienvenue ici au bistr du
théâtre à montiné le bretonne maire de
plaisir encarté à l'UMP élu en mars
dernier avec un peu plus de 58 % des
suffrages dès le premier tour en poste
depuis 2012 et le départ de Joë R qui
vous a passé la main vous êtes aussi la
présidente de la communauté de communes
de l'Ouest parisien beaucoup de
responsabilités politique préparant cet
entretien j'ai tout de même découvert un
petit peu parce que je finalement je je
ne me souvenais pas de ça que vous étiez
avant scénariste interprète traductrice
comédienne metteur en scène oui c'était
comment cette vie d'avant c'était bien
vous la regrettez un petit peu non non
je la regrette pas non bien sûr que non
Ctait c'est un choix de ma part très
très réfléchi parce que pendant un
certain temps j'ai eu une concomitance
entre la vie politique en tant
qu'adjointe à la culture et ma vie
professionnelle effectivement de m en
scène de théâtre et à un moment donné
ben il a fallu faire un choix et je l'ai
fait mais sans aucun regret vraiment
vous avez signé des adaptations de bande
dessiné notamment les Bidochons par
exemple quel souvenir vous gardez de
votre vie d'avant voilà justement ah je
garde un souvenir extraordinaire parce
que j'ai fait des rencontres
particulièrement fortes ne serait-ce que
tout le travail avec FL gaassial avec
Monsieur Binet qui était le dessinateur
des bdechamp avec qui j'ai travaillé sur
l'adaptation CARM cru également puisqu a
plus de 700 représentations sur les deux
hein que ce soit lib d'Uchon carmenain
cru alors je peux pas dire que je sois
une spécialiste de la bande ciné mais en
tout cas pendant cette période oui avec
la compagnie on l'a été et on a fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
représentation que ce soit en France ou
en Europe et ça a été vraiment une une
vie passionnante de tourner ben un petit
peu ce que les gens savent du théâtre et
et des et des compagnies théâtrales qui
fonctionnent bien on a eu cette chance
de très très bien fonctionné et vous
avez fait ensuite ce passage vers la
politique vous l'avez dit en étant tout
d'abord adjointe à la culture comment ça
s les choses se sont engagé un petit peu
ben c'està dire je connaissais Monsieur
Joël Rignot dans d'autres circonstances
de façon amicale
et tout à fait l'ancien maire de plaisir
et encore suppléant de Monsieur David
Douillet hein pour ne pas le citer et
puis on se connaissait il suivait aussi
mon parcours puisqu'on a eu la chance
pendant un certain temps de partager les
mêmes bureaux lui il avait sa permanence
en tant que conseil régional et moi
j'étais donc responsable de cette
compagnie théâtrale puisque à l'époque
ben ça marchait très très bien comme je
vous le disais même si monter des
spectacles qui s'apparentaient plus à du
classique à ce moment-là et il il était
dans cette dynamique de vouloir se
présenter comme maire sur la ville de
plaisir donc il m'a fait cette
proposition qui m'a quand même beaucoup
surprise au départ parce que je vous
avoue que j'étais citoyen Landa et je me
demandais bien en quoi ça pouvait
correspondre d'être adjointe à la
culture sur une ville comme plaisir et
puis finalement ça m'a bien tenté donc
je suis rentré tout doucement pour voir
un petit peu comment ça se passait et
vous avez attrapé le virus de la
politique tout de suite vous êtes dit
faut que j'aille encore après plus loin
que la la culture ça s'est pas passé
comme ça je m'en suis pas rendue compte
moi-même je crois qu'il y a eu des
choses qui ont été plutôt des évidences
vous savez quand on fait du théâtre ou
quand on est professeur parce que
j'aiétais professeur également dans dans
dans une école internationale sur la
production de spectacle vivant et bien
vous donnez vous donnez vous êtes à
l'écoute vous êtes dans une proximité
des très grande avec les gens et
finalement c'était pas une continuité
mais presque alors je voudrais pas vous
entendre dire que la politique est ça se
ressemble beaucoup c'est la
représentation de la mise en scène on
sou SC en politique c'est un peu vrai
quand même c'est oui bien sûrez la
preuve est bien là je suis sous les
projecteurs ça me change pas beaucoup
parce que j'étais comédienne aussi donc
on pourrait dire que je peux m'en servir
non c'est plutôt un atout supplémentaire
d'être à l'aise mais c'est surtout je
dirais cette volonté de de s'occuper
d'un vrai projet et d'être mère je
trouve c'est un projet extraordinaire
parce que vous êtes en proximité des
gens et je pense avoir au moins cette
qualité là c'est d'aimer les gens la
page de la culture la page de la
représentation cette vie d'avant elle
est oubliée ou quelquefois vous en êtes
nostalgique et vous vous dites pourquoi
pas après plus tard après la politique
recommencer un peu ouais j'aimerais
avoir 40 ans pour pouvoir dire après
plus tard j'ai pas 40 ans
malheureusement c'est pas une question
d'âge forcément on peut toujours après
retourner malgré tout c'est pourquoi pas
on sait jamais je sais pas du tout vous
savez je pas fermé la porte en tout cas
je ferme la porte à rien absolument à
rien je me dis que les opportunités font
les choses et puis il y a des logiques
aussi qui font les choses donc
aujourd'hui je suis en politique j'y
suis très très bien j'ai un regard
toujours très très proche de la culture
qu'elle soit sur la collectivité mais
bien au-delà aussi et je pense que la
culture est toujours quelque chose de
fondamental pour trouver je dirais un
lien et un lien avec la population donc
voilà je suis toujours dedans je reviens
un petit peu sur ce que vous disiez
juste avant et parce que vous l'avez
déclaré aussi lors de de de votre
élection en mars dernier ce qui vous
motive c'est c'est aussi d'être prête à
servir vous êtes prêt à servir vous
l'avez redit en mars dernier servir
aider la population être au service de
la population oui oui c'est vrai alors
ce don on se rend compte c'est que j'en
parlais il y a quelques minutes
justement cette chronophagie je dirait
du du du temps que l'on a et la
proximité avec la population et c'est
quelque chose qui me tient fortement à
cœur et j'essaie vraiment d'être
présente auprès de auprès de tout le
monde auprès des enfants dans les
cantines auprès des des commerçants
puisqu'on on travaille beaucoup avec les
commerçants auprès des entreprises et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est cette
proximité là c'est pour ça que cette
fonction de M je trouve elle est
importante cette proximité quelque chose
qui manque aujourd'hui justement à la
population on le sent tout s'éloigne
tout devient de plus en plus brumeux
obscure incompréhensible même et je
pense que oui moi je suis toujours dans
cette volonté là toujours je vais vous
amener à présent sur un autre terrain
qui va pas forcément vous plaire vous
êtes une femme est-ce que ça change des
choses en politique lorsqu'on est à la
tête d'une des plus importantes communes
des IV c'est la 7 7e commune des
iblelines avec un peu plus de 30000
habitants une des rares femmes aussi
présidente d'agglomération de communauté
de commune ça ça change quelque chose
est-ce que c'est plus difficile en
politique est-ce que vous avez perçu les
choses comme plus dur il y a eu plus de
preuves à faire je sens pas ou alors je
n'y pense pas à vrai dire est est-ce
qu'on vous le dit est-ce que non on me
dit les choses différemment on me dit
par exemple êtes-vous vous êtes
consciente que vous vous tenez une ville
de cette importance madame le Maire je
dis est-ce que vous poseriez cette
question à un homme ça oui on me l'a dit
plusieurs fois je pense qu'il y a encore
cette surprise que on puisse avoir des
responsabilités de cette envergure je
vous avoue que au quotidien moi j'y
pense pas du tout
j'aborde le monde politique où il y a
énormément d'hommes parce que dans les
grandes réunions vous voyez surtout
beaucoup d'hommes il y a très très peu
de femmes encore mais je je me sens ni
différente ni supérieure ni inférieure
je me sens tout à fait dans une
dynamique de travail et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse vous êtes dans une dynamique
de de combat aussi peut-être en tout cas
vous avez une une forte volonté ça
revient peut-être aussi à l'enfance vous
êtes arrivé en France à 6 ans vous ne
parliez pas français vous avez été
naturalisé à 14 ans c'est ça aussi qui a
forgé votre caractère de vouloir prouver
vous imposer jamais baisser les bras oui
sûrement sûrement on m'a appris dans ma
famille qu'il fallait travailler on m'a
appris qu'il fallait respecter on m'a
appris qu'il fallait s'intégrer de façon
je dirais naturelle et peut-être j'en
sais rien mais je crois que vous savez
on change pas beaucoup hein quand on est
tout petit vous regardez un enfant en
général s'il est tonique dynamique et
ben il le sera toute sa vie euh donc je
crois que j'avais ça en moi c'est pas
tellement ce côté-là mais je m'en sers
pas de ce côté-là mais ça me permet de
comprendre beaucoup de choses
l'intégration euh les difficultés des
uns et des autres ça me permet d'être au
plus proche et ça me permet d'être plus
dur aussi euh quand par exemple j'ai
quelque chose à dire sur ces
difficultéslà je peux dire que je l'ai
vécu et que je sais ce que c'est alors
aujourd'hui on me dit oui mais enfin
italienne c'est facile oui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est presque d'être italien
mais à l'époque quand je suis arrivée
avec mes parents je peux vous dire que
on était pas regardé de la même façon
donc je suis tout très au fait de ces de
tout ça quel lien vous gardez avec votre
pays d'origine d'ailleurs avecitalien
complète j'ai toute ma famille là-bas je
parle italien voulez que je parle
l'italien
[Rires]
je non non ma famille est là-bas toute
ma famille et j'y vais régulièrement le
plus possible et vous savez pourquoi j'y
vais non seulement pour les voir mais
j'y vais pour prendre du sourire et du
soleil je crois qu'on a besoin de ça le
sourire la pétillance dans les yeux je
la retrouve encore là-bas en Italie elle
y est malgré les difficulté on arrive
encore à avoir ça alors je dis pas qu'en
France on est triste mais on est un peu
morose donc j'essaie d'apporter ça quand
vousz entendre tout ce débat autour de
l'Europe de sortir de l'Europe ça doit
ça doit vous gêner quelque part parce
que voilà vous parlez de ces échanges et
de l'enrichissement mutuel entre les
pays donc forcément le débat autour de
moi une pro européenne à fond vous savez
dans mon bureau c'est très symptomatique
il y a deux drapeaux le français
l'Européen mon fauteuil est à côté du
drapeau européen ça veut pas dire je me
sens pas française bien évidemment que
si mais l'Europe pour moi c'est c'est
l'avenir c'est une évidence ça n'enlève
pas la personnalité des gens ça n'enlève
pas les caractéristiques des pays mais
ça nous donne une force et une force
c'est pas pour combattre c'est c'est
pour construire et on a vraiment besoin
de ça aujourd'hui je crois qu'on devrait
avoir un petit peu un regard un petit
peu différent par rapport à l'Europe
parce qu'on est très critique en ce
moment on va s'arrêter là pour cette
première partie d'émission on va passer
dans la salle de ce bistro du théâtre à
Montini pour évoquer quelquesuns des
dossiers qui vous occupent sur votre
[Musique]
commun seconde partie de ce café
politique toujours avec Joséphine
colmans berger la mre de plaisir je vous
propose d'écouter quelquesuns de vos
administrés qui parlent de la commune
des plus des moins s'ils apprécient ou
non de vivre à Plaisir écoutez bah le
négatif c'est la circulation qui devient
de plus en plus dur à circuler quand
même dans le centre commercial mais même
sur la 30 et tout ça le point positif
c'est peut-être le sport à plaisir parce
qu'on est bien quand même on a des super
infrastructures ce que j'aime bien c'est
qu'on a tout à proximité on a beaucoup
de on a des grands centres commerciaux
effectivement pourrait faire les travaux
qui ont été annoncés depuis un petit
moment
déjà les travaux valibou quoi les
bâtiments sont ancien et dégradé les
trottoirs sont pas très bien aménagés
c'est plus pour les voitures par moment
les piétons ils sont pe embêté quoi je
veux dire sur plaisir j'ai l'impression
que si on n pas de voiture bah le piéton
il est pas le bienvenu peut-être
dynamiser un peu plus le le centreeville
oui c'est vrai que et puis le fameux
cinéma je serais assez sensible au fait
que ça se ça aboutisse parce que ça
manque ça manque un cinéma sur la sur la
commune alors il était question de la
proximité des infrastructures sportives
pour faire les courses pour la vie
quotidienne tout ça c'était plutôt
positif c'était pas le cas en revanche
pour la circulation les aménagements
pour les piétons le cinéma le quartier
du du valibou également ça ce sont les
les for qui sont attendus peut-être tout
d'abord sur la circulation se déplacer à
plaisir c'est toujours un petit peu
compliqué ne serait-ce que parce que il
y a beaucoup de centres commerciaux qui
attire beaucoup de population extérieure
est-ce que surt ça des réflexions sont
en cours des aménagements sont prévus
oui bien sûr alors on a on a un grand
retard qui est le retard de
l'élargissement de la RD30 que tout le
monde connaît malheureusement mais ça y
est les travaux ont démarré ont débuté
avant Noël et là on est vraiment sur le
démarrage de chantier qui est pas simple
puisque j'ai déjà prévenu par
information à la population qu'on en a
pour minimum 36 mois d'élargissement
faut savoir qu'on a 15 ans 20 ans de
retard sur cet élargissement qui a été
bloqué par pas mal de d'associations
avec des recours qui veut dire que
forcément et bien on aurait pu déjà
profiter de ça la circulation en ce qui
concerne le centre-ville de la ville de
Plaisir est complexe dû justement à
cette problématique de la RD 30 je suis
très positive sur le fait qu'une fois
les travaux terminés on ait une
circulation beaucoup plus softe au
niveau des trottoir puisque j'ai entendu
des REM des piétons qui étaient assez
mis à l'écart c'est le sentiment c'est
le sentimentou si c'est le sentiment moi
je veux bien le
croiretim bien sûr on a on a on a
beaucoup amélioré surtout sur le centre
ville autour de l'église il y a eu des
trottoirs qui ont été complètement remis
à neuf il y a des circulations sur des
axes importants c'est un vrai travail de
réflexion on a tout un plan pluriannuel
qui va être fait sur la mandature par
rapport à cette sécurisation des
trottoirs et aménagement pour les PMR
bien évidemment puisque auourd'hui j'y
suis très attachée pour qu'on ait cette
amélioration là donc oui bien sûr on a
une feuille de route très précise entre
maintenant et 2020 pour vraiment
apporter à une qualité de vie au niveau
de la circulation piétonne plus
importante on fait très attention
également aux nouvelles pistes cyclables
à mettre en place et la circulation
douce verte comme on peut l'appeler qui
me tient aussi également à cœur
puisqu'on a un rue qui traverse la ville
et j'espère bien pouvoir faire toute une
continuité de promenade par rapport à
tout ça vous parliz des travaux juste
justement des travaux d'aménagement de
et de de rénovation sur le quartier du
valiibou parce qu'il y sur quartier HLM
quartier plutôt difficile des travaux
qui ont été entamé des premières
tranches la deuxième tranche les travaux
ont été bloqués ça a repris ça a été
très très compliqué la population
l'attend pour le cadre de vie et et pas
seulement on en est où de ce dossier du
quartier du valiibbou parce que c'est
avec les bailleurs sociaux que vous
discutez beaucoup et ça Blou je suis
contente que vous me posiez cette
question parce que euh parce que je me
bats là-dessus on se bat là-dessus en
permanence ça fait 2 années que je suis
je dirais à bras de fer un peu avec
l'opivois pour ne pas le
citer alors qu'est-ce qu'il bloque il
bloque deux choses d'abord que ils ont
pris énormément de retard sur la
deuxième tranche de la réhabilitation
pour des raisons j'imagine financières
et ce qui nous pose souci aujourd'hui
c'est ces fameux travaux d'amiante comme
vous le savez il y a des normes qui ont
changé et qui aujourd'hui impactent
énormément les travaux ce qui fait que
et bien ça a demander des études
complémentaires dans les appartements et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve même avec une
configuration de réhabilitation de 2è
tranche qui sera pas à l'équivalent de
la première tranche mais qui doivent
commencer en 2015 l'intérêt de tout cela
c'est pas que la je veux dire que ça
commence en 2015 c'est que la trème
tranche sera tout de suite dans dans la
suite la population le sait aujourd'hui
moi je suis au côté de des habitants au
côté des associations qui se battent
effectivement non seulement pour que ça
se fasse vite mais qu'en plus et bien
nous puissions s'il le faut moi je je
l'ai dit je me suis engagé avec la
population S faut descendre dans la rue
pour que les choses accélèrent j'irai
avec eux ils le savent c'est pas du tout
pour faire de la démagogie c'est
vraiment parce que je ressens que c'est
une véritable nécessité aujourd'hui si
je peux me permettre de dire une chose
sur cette norme de la miante et je veux
voudrais me faire le porte-parole et là
si les maires collègues m'entendent je
pense qu'ils vont être d'accord avec moi
c'est que aujourd'hui ces normesl sont
en train de tuer complètement les
réhabilitations de tous ces centre de
toutes ces habitations sociales ce qui
veut dire que dans quelques années on va
avoir un parc d'habitation sociale qui
va être dégradé complètement et en plus
ça enlève complètement le travail aux
entreprises qui pourrai travailler qui
ne peuvent pas à cause de ces normes qui
sont drastiques donc faudrait que tout
le monde y réfléchisse un peu je crois
même les parlementaires mais il faut des
normes malgré tout il y a des questions
de sécurité qui se POS je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous mais là
on est parti dans une exagération qui
demande aux entreprises que vous soyez
obligé de confiner des appartements
sortir des personnes uniquement pour
changer des radiateurs vous voyez un
petit peu je trouve que là on est un peu
passé de l'autre côté de la
norme évidentecessif en tout cas juste
avant d'écouter votre opposant au
conseil municipal socialiste Bernard
hsard qui vous posera une question comme
cette tradition dans cette émission une
réponse aussi par rapport au micro
trottoir que nous avons réalisé sur le
cinéma qui est proche de la galerie
commerciale de de l'hypermarché l'ancien
a été fermé est-ce que des repreneurs
vont venir est-ce qu'un cinéma va voir
le jour un multiplex peut-être à Plaisir
simplement rappeler que le cinéma qui
était en place il y a quelques années
était un cinéma qui était installé dans
dans un local qui ne nous appartenait h
et le propriétaire de l'époque donc nous
a demandé de partir parce que des
travaux devaient se faire ensuite cette
société a fait faillite maintenant ça a
été
racheté on est très avancé sur ce projet
très très avancé alors pas nous nous en
partenariat avec bien évidemment la
société qui a racheté et aujourd'hui
nous sommes sur un dépôt de permis de
construire qui va arriver le projet est
effectivement une ouverture de cinéma de
6 à salle de cinéma avec à proximité des
enseignes et des restaurants c'est un
très grand centre commercial qui doit
voir le jour et l'intérêt de ce centre
avec les cinémas qui est quand même le
floron de ce qui est attendu par les
Plaisirois c'est l'amélioration de tout
le quartier c'està-dire les places
adjacentes les rond-points qui vont être
construits les agrandissements de rue
donc tout ça ça a un impact non
seulement commercial mais bien sur
l'habitat de toute la zone qui va être
complètement changée sur les deux tro
années à venir on écoute à présent
Bernard ansard il va vous poser la
prochaine question ça concerne les
rythmes
scolaires dès le mois de septembre vous
avez choisi d'appliquer la réforme des
rythmes scolaires à minima privant ainsi
les élèves de primaire d'activités
culturell artistique et aussi
sportive des activités prévues hors du
temps scolaire de façon sans distinction
et de façon
équitable ce choix fait sur des
considérations
budgétaire font que on laisse de côté
l'aspect social et solidaire aujourd'hui
beaucoup de beaucoup de mécontentement
des parents des enseignants mais aussi
des personnels de la mairie en grève sur
une majorité de maternelle sur le mois
de
décembre une attente forte pour avoir
des conditions d'accueil des enfants
améliorés pouvez-vous me dire
concrètement ce que vous comptez faire à
court terme mais aussi également pour la
rentrée scolaire 2015 alors les rythmes
scolaires comme de nombreux maires vous
étiez contre vous avez même lancé ça a
été repris au niveau national cette
récré àont pour qualifier ces ces tap
ces temps d'activités périscolair
Bernard har demande si ça va changer et
est-ce que ça va changer est-ce qu'il y
aura plus d'activités et quand est-ce
que la rentrée prochaine il y aura des
aménagements j'avais dit que pour des
raisons budgétaire effectivement puisque
les 770000 € qui nous aent été demandé
pour cette mise en place était pas
absolument pas
envisageable j'avais souhaité que nous
démarrions effectivement à minima comme
monsieur hsard c'est pas franchement un
minima mais enfin on va dire ça comme ça
euh au mois de septembre et de faire un
point à la fin du premier trimestre
chose que nous allons faire puisque je
vais recevoir les parents d'élèves au
mois de janvier dans une grande réunion
pour justement faire un point sur cette
rentrée qui effectivement a été calme au
niveau de de la rentrée scolaire qui a
démontré quelques difficultés mais ce
qui est normal dans tout changement il y
a toujours des difficultés mais en
grande majorité les choses se sont
plutôt très bien passées alors monsieur
hsard il évoque des greffes de personnel
hein tout de même he des parents méc ou
al alors je crois qu'il est pas tout à
fait au fait des choses puisque greffe
de personnel c'était vraiment très am
minima et ça a duré 2 3 jours et c'était
pas l'ensemble des du personnel c'était
quelques personnes que je respecte bien
sûr que j'ai rencontré et effectivement
qui n'avaent pas eu l'information que
des réunions de travail étaient déjà en
cours malheureusement comme quoi les
information des fois ne redescendent pas
c'est bien dommageable donc j'en seraai
très vigilante la prochaine fois mais on
est tout à fait au fait des difficultés
qu'il peut y avoir aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui va se passer plus d'activités après
est-ce que vous allez proposer plus de
chos il va se passer que maintenant que
nous avons on va avoir un un je dirais
un point de recul avec un bilan on va
pouvoir échanger voir quelles sont les
attentes à la fois des parents et les
attentes au niveau des difficultés
d'encadrement que ce soit les adsèes les
dames de cantine ou la jeunesse bien
évidemment on veut améliorer ça
c'est-à-dire que cette
récréamont et bien va certainement être
traité d' une autre façon intégré d'une
autre façon avec une amélioration au
niveau des activités alors bien sûr que
ça demande un travail ce travail va être
fait sur l'année qui va venir pour
pouvoir se préparer à la rentrée du mois
de septembre mais la première des choses
pour moi c'est d'entendre les parents je
sais une chose conclurai là-dessus c'est
que c'est les changements qui pose
problème toujours et les parents
aujourd'hui se sont accoutumés à ce
rythme que nous avons mis en place je
pense que si nous rechangeons à nouveau
la totalité des choses ça risque d'être
très problématique aussi bien pour les
personnes qui travaillent que pour ceux
qui ne travaillent pas donc on va être
très à l'écoute la seconde question à
présent elle porte on va sortir un petit
peu de plaisir sur l'intercommunalité
rest la deième question donc concerne
l'intercommunalité la loi prévoit que
les
intercommunalités doivent avoir un
minimum de 200000 habitants nous venons
de façon unanime rejeter le plan du
préfet qui voulait nous inclure dans une
aglo de 800000 habitants sur 58 communes
des ensembles qui posent des enjeux
importants pour l'avenir des habitants
mais aussi des Plaisirois que ça soit
pour la fiscalité la gestion des sols
l'urbanisme mais aussi la vie économique
vous avez émis le souit unique de
rejoindre la casquie un choix arbitraire
plus sur des considérations
politiques pouvez-vous nous dire au-delà
de ce fait comment vous argumentez votre
choix de rejoindre la casquille et
comment vous comptez associer les
habitants à cette décision je vous
remercie alors sur cette question de
l'intercommunalité plaisir qui
appartient depuis peu à une communauté
de commune avec villepreu avec les clés
il va falloir se rapprocher des autres
agglomérations c'est la loi pour élargir
un petit peu le cadre et mieux fédérer
mutualiser les moyens ce choix de 50 ans
en iveline il est purement politique
comme le dit Bernard mais non puisquil
était fait avant quand 50 ans en yvline
était pas du même bord que nous donc je
veux dire on peut pas déjà nous affubler
ça parce que c'est pas c'est
complètement abscond par contre le fait
que nous soyons dans une logique
géographique et dans une évidence de
territoire oui ça ça me semble important
de de le rappeler alors quand il évoque
les 800000 bien évidemment puisque
monsieur hsard fait partie aussi de la
CCOP il sait très bien que nous avons
voté contre aussi bien au niveau de la
ville qu'au niveau de de
l'intercommunalité personne n'en veut
hein de cette super agglomération à
800000 habitant enfin ce que je voudrais
dire et rassurer c'est que je me bats en
permanence pas uniquement et toute seule
avec avec les maires et aussi avec
Monsieur logier pour ne pas le citer de
la casquie pour pour que ces 800000 ne
passent pas nous nous sommes rapproché
de parlementaires et même de Monsieur
Larcher pour nous accompagner dans cette
démarche pour qu'effectivement on écoute
moi je pense que c'est antidémocratique
que de vouloir nous imposer ces 800000
alors que tout le monde a dit non on ne
peut absolument pas passer outre donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas une bataille que
nous sommes en train de faire c'est du
travail que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place avec la bien sûr avec
morpas avec coignère qui sont censés
aussi rentrer avec nous dans cette
réflexion là je CIS que pour coignère ce
sera plus compliqué he du côté de
coignère le ma ne veut pas il me semble
que le mère ne veut pas il a organisé un
réend récemment même sa je suis
quelqu'un d'optimiste je me dis
que oui j'ai bien peur mais bon on va
essayer quand même on va essayer de de
voir moi je vais vous dire je je
souhaite pas rentrer ou partir à la
casquille être avec la casqu uniquement
comme ça sans réflexion il y a tout un
travail de préparation à faire qui a
plus de 30 ans d'existence nous nous
sommes une intercommunalité toute petite
mais malgré tout représentant 62000
personnes c'est pas anodin avec morpa et
coignère parce que je continue de le
dire et bien nous pourrions
effectivement remettre à plat les choses
et avoir une une réflexion en commun
pour que nous ne soyons pas perdant dans
cette opération parce que je suis
consciente comme dit Monsieur hsard il
doit bien imaginer que j'ai cette
réflexion là sur l'intelligence du
respect de la population du territoire
des sols comme il l'évoque et bien
évidemment aujourd'hui j'ai la je suis
Madame le Maire bien sûr mais j'ai aussi
ma casquette de présidente et c'est le
respect aussi de notre communauté de
commune de l'Ouest parisien la
population sera associée est-ce que vous
pouvez organiser des référendum sur
cette question voulez-vous ou non
rejoindre saintqutin en iveline ou
est-ce que le choix est d'ors déjà acté
moi je considère que la population quand
on est proche de sa population on
connaît sa population et on s'est
suffisamment communiqué les référendum
pour moi c'est pas le meilleur moyen de
commun avec sa population je suis je
suis nous sommes les maires la Derco
suffisamment je pense proche pour pour
prendre des décisions ils nous ont élu
ils nous ont fait confiance il faut
maintenant qu'on leur fasse preuve de
nos responsabilités donc je n'irai pas
vers un référendum il en est pas
question puisqu'on a commencé à sortir
de plaisir on va terminer avec un mot
sur le canton le canton de plaisir qui
regroupe ti ver valgrigon lesclés sous
boois Ben également vous êtes candidate
en mars prochain 22 29 mars candidate
avec un binô puisque c'est la la
nouvelle règle c'est Bertrand coocard
pour pour l'UDI c'est le socialiste
Jean-Michel Gourdon qui est le le
sortant sur ce canton votre état
d'esprit avant la campagne qui va
débuter dans les prochaines semaines on
va gagner tout VO bien pierre b
président actuel du conseil général veut
le grand chlem donc oui c'est tout à
fait tout à fait il y a pas de raison
que ça ne se passe pas comme ça encore
une fois c'est pour pouvoir travailler
c'est il faut avoir cette volonté là et
le moment venu on en parlera plus en
détail mais départemental c'est un
échelon important parce qu'on parlait
des intercommunalités juste avant ça
fait beaucoup d'échelon tout de même la
population en plus qui se mobilise déjà
assz peu sur les élections départemental
là ça risque d'être encore plus
compliqué d'ailleurs mais bon c'est
encore une autre réflexion mais
l'échelon départemental sur sa nécessité
quelle est votre réflexion làdessus
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas prendre les
compétences et remettre sur les
agglomérations est-ce que ça a un sens
je vous évoquis tout à l'heure la
proximité alors le département est
encore quelque chose qui représente une
proximité mais si vraiment je devais
vous dire les choses je pense qu'il y a
des strates sont de trop aujourd'hui on
souffre nous les collectivités de
problématiques financières parce que
justement il y a trop d'échelon et trop
de millefeuilles des compétences
croisées dans tous les domaines il y a
un vrai travail à faire alors peut-être
pas uniquement dans des suppressions
mais peut-être dans des analyses de
compétences qui sont peut-être dédoublés
triplé quadruplé et il y a un gros
travail de de de remise à plat ça j'en
suis convaincu
euh oui il y en a trop trop et puis
justement puis que nous parlions des des
élections départementales café politique
va s'arrêter un temps afin de traiter de
manière équitable bien évidemment
l'ensemble des candidats et pour nous
permettre aussi de préparer des
rendez-vous spéciaux sur TVfil prochain
café politique ce sera donc dans
quelques semaines quelques mois en avril
merci josephberg MRE de plaisir et d'ici
là je vous retrouve bien évidemment du
lundi au vendredi 18h pour le
[Musique]
journal